In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinoxadion, for May 24, on which we commemorate our righteous
Father Simeon of the wondrous mountain.
On the 24th of the month we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father Simeon, the
younger Stylite of the wonderful mountain.
Our holy and God-bearing Father Simeon was born in Antioch in 521, of parents who were
perfumers from Odessa.
His birth had been foretold to his mother St. Martha by the Holy Forerunner, who told
her the child's name and predicted that he would follow St. John's own example and live
an ascetic life.
Even without pain, Simeon would only accept his mother's right breast and refused to suck
when she had eaten meat.
After his baptism at the age of two, he began to speak and repeated for seven days.
I have a Father and I have no Father.
I have a Mother and I have no Mother.
Showing in this way his perfect detachment from earthly things.
At the age of five he miraculously escaped along with his mother from an earthquake in which
his Father perished, trapped under the ruins of his house.
Sometime later the child saw Christ, surrounded by a multitude of the righteous on the wall
of the city and was taught by him how to acquire wisdom and escape God's punishment.
A man clothed in white then appeared to Simeon and called him to follow him to a mountain
situated about eight miles from Antioch in the direction of Salusia where he spent several
days alone in the company of wild beasts.
The child then discovered a small monastery under the direction of a styleite called John
who had been forewarned in visions of his arrival.
He welcomed him with joy as one chosen of God and immediately accepted him under his spiritual
direction, amazed at the signs of wisdom in and the frugality of this child of six who
only ate every third or seventh day.
With the beginning of his life in the monastery, Simeon worked his first miracle.
He healed a shepherd who, being jealous of him, had wanted to kill him and had been punished
by the withering of his right hand.
As he desired to imitate his spiritual father in everything, after having been proved in
his intention for a year, he set up a sort of short pillar next to John's column and thus
began his career as a styleite at the age of seven.
He was encouraged in this by a vision in which Christ revealed to him that standing upright
on a pillar would be for him like his crucifixion, and the means of imitating his saving passion.
Resplendent as the sun, living in angelic perfection and filled with divine gifts,
wrote his biographer, the child stripped himself entirely of the things of earth and directed
his soul towards heaven.
He continually added new labors to his battle against nature.
When John read thirty Psalms during his nocturnal prayer, Simeon would read fifty or eighty.
He kept vigil every night, sometimes reciting the entire Psalter, and spent the day glorifying
God, remaining a stranger to all earthly food.
His austerities produced a remonstrance from the abbot who said to him, it only remains
to you to take up a sword and destroy yourself.
He also reproached him for not letting the other monks sleep by his uninterrupted solmity
and recommended that Simeon simply follow his own example.
John replied to his master using the words of Scripture and saying that, although he made
no condemnation of others, he himself needed such austerities in order that his intellect
should not let itself be weighed down by attachment to material things.
The child's styleite showed the ardor of a seasoned warrior in the battle against the demons,
where attacks alternated with heavenly visions that came to strengthen him.
In one vision, an elderly patriarch came to anoint him with perfume in order to repel
all the attacks of the demons.
Once a frightening tempest provoked by the devil, uprooted, and blew away the shelter in which
the saints stood on his column.
In the morning, the monks found Simeon still standing on his pillar, his face shining
like that of an angel.
Even before losing his milk-teeth, the child had already acquired the power to heal and
to deliver the possessed.
He would exhort the monks with the wisdom of an elder to overcome their passions through
guarding their senses and their intellect, and he even drew up a cinematic rule of life
for them, based on holy scripture.
He used to say, the pride of the monk is temperance.
The pride of the monk is continually to read the Psalms and to pray unceasingly.
The pride of the monk is obedience.
For by it the Lord conquered death by becoming obedient unto death on the cross.
His fame as an ascetic and wonder-workers spread rapidly throughout the region and resulted
in a visit from the patriarch of Antioch, St. Ephrem, and from the vast crowds that frequented
the place to receive the blessing of the two stylites.
To the austerities and voluntary privations that Simeon inflicted on his body, he added an
immeasurable charity so that if any came to him without clothes, he would strip himself
completely of the ones he was wearing, even in winter, and would endure months of bitter
cold, warmed only by divine grace.
For a whole year he remained in a crouching position, so that his knees stuck together and
his thighs, and the back of his knees became infected with gangrene, producing a fetid odor,
alerted to this by the smell the monks sent a doctor whom Simeon refused, and it was
by divine intervention that he was healed.
As a thanksgiving for his healing he remained kneeling for many days.
One pentacost, the Holy Spirit descended on the saint and filled him with wisdom and knowledge
so that he began to compose discourses on the spiritual life, destined both for monks
and layfolk, according to the word, out of the mouths of babes and sucklings as thou ordained
strength.
Having become a light of the Holy Spirit by the age of thirteen in the year 533, Simeon
after spending six years on the pillar and desiring to imitate the heavenward movement
of his glorious predecessor, Simeon stylites the elder, built a column more than twelve
feet high.
This was considerably higher than that of his spiritual father, who complained that he was
no longer able to see his disciples face.
Once the column was built and Simeon was about to climb it, the archbishop of Antioch and
the bishop of Salusia came to visit the monastery and ordained him deacon.
They then formed a procession and accompanied him with hymns and prayers to the column, where
he was to spend eight years reaching out towards heaven with all his being.
After the death of his spiritual father of which he had been warned by a divine revelation,
the direction of the community passed to Simeon until the end of his life.
Yet he did not abate his ascetic strivings in the least nor let himself be distracted from
his continual prayer by the practical task of running the monastery.
When closed in a shelter of skin, without light or air, he would remain in prayer from
sunset until dawn, and holding on with his left hand would beat his breast with his right,
soaking his hair shirt with his tears.
He would chant the whole salter accompanied by angelic voices, then recite the book of wisdom
and the gospels and finish his prayers at sunrise in order to take a short rest.
After having sensed the column, without needing to light his censor, he went so far as to deprive
himself entirely of sleep for thirty days and nights, begging God to release him from the tyranny
of nature.
But at the end of this period, a heavenly voice said to him, you must sleep a little.
This progress, in rising up towards God, provoked redoubled attacks on the part of the demons
who sought to throw him from his column, but the saint, helped by three angels, energetically
repulsed them.
God therefore showed him increased favor with visions, miracles, and even resurrection of
a dead man, and finally Christ appeared to him to give him the power of casting out all
impure spirits.
The angels then withdrew, leaving the saint as the only steward of divine grace on behalf
of the crowds of sick and possessed people who came running to him to beg him to heal them.
Simeon acted in everything as the Lord had done during his earthly life.
He would command the demons with the voice of authority, restore, correct, and edify souls
and bodies, so that through him, God might reign among men.
He would heal the sick by his word, by the laying on of his hands, or his almondwood staff,
by the touching of the hem of his garments, by a simple contact with dust or oil blessed
by him, or even by a lamp lit in his honor, or the simple invocation of his name.
In the course of one of his visions, he was warned of the forthcoming capture of the city
of Antioch by Krosos, King of the Persians, in June in the year 540.
This prophecy, being fulfilled, the city was set a light, and its inhabitants massacred
or exiled, while the barbarians spread throughout the countryside, devastating the land.
When they arrived within sight of the monastery, Simeon's prayer was able to repel them, yet
the fear of a new massacre so terrified the monks that they all abandoned the monastery,
in spite of the saints' exhortations.
When the Persians arrived, the two angels whom God had sent to protect Simeon put them
to flight, and after three days the monks were able to return to the monastery.
And Simeon then freed a great number of prisoners who had invoked his name in their distress,
including a monk who had abandoned him during the siege of the city.
His fame, having spread throughout the land, he was not able to enjoy the solitude he desired.
So, at the age of twenty in the year 541, he decided to leave his column to return to the
lonely place, pathless and inhabited by wild beasts, where he had spent some time as a child.
In a vision Christ showed him the summit of the mountain, which by that time was called
the wonderful mountain, a rock that the divine glory had covered with its shadow.
As Simeon climbed the mountain on which he would stand as a natural column, the community
of monks abandoned the monastery below and followed him to settle there in temporary
shacks with no comfort.
From the first day he was there, the crowds, having found the monastery deserted, discovered
this new place of retirement, and, making away for themselves through the forest, came to
present all their ills to him.
Filled with sadness but unable to refuse to put his prayer at the service of God's suffering
people, Simeon continued to work miracles and healings.
When a terrible plague fell upon the Byzantine Empire, striking Constantinople and Antioch
particularly brutally in 542, only those who invoked the Saints' aid found themselves spared
by the scourge.
Afterwards an earthquake that the saint had predicted rocked the city of Antioch in 551.
For several days the terrified inhabitants prayed night and day, and traveled to the wonderful
mountain to beg the man of God to intercede on their behalf, and indeed Saint Simeon's prayers
put an end to the disaster.
A thousands of the possessed and sick end of pilgrims traveled to this barren and waterless
place to see the saint, the Lord told Simeon that he was about to provide for their needs,
an angel appeared and traced the plan of a vast monastery and church on the ground exactly
where the stylite stood, and a luminous cloud covered the wonderful mountain.
A short time later a large number of men from Isaria from Simeon had healed, arrived, and
began to build.
They were replaced by other groups who succeeded one another so that the building grew rapidly
without disturbing the monks who were able to continue to devote themselves to the work
of God.
The saint caused abundant water to Gushforth, and at his prayer the water never dried up.
In the center of the church dedicated to the Holy Trinity and the monastic buildings constructed
in the form of a cross, a new column was erected for the saint.
On the 4th of June, in 551, Saint Simeon descended from the rocky spur on which he had stood
for ten years, and placed by his monks on a throne and holding the Holy Gospels against
his breast, was carried around the monastery to bless all the buildings, preceded by his
mother Saint Martha who carried the cross singing Alleluia.
The monks then took him in their hands like a sacred vessel and bowing down before him
placed him on the platform of the new column, which Christ, appearing in all his glory, had
just blessed.
From the top of this column, from which the saint one day saw a ladder reaching to the
gate of heaven, Simeon did not forget to watch over the good order of the monastery.
The saint strictly forbade the monks to eat the foodstuffs brought as offerings by the
pilgrims.
They were to work in the monastery gardens below to support their own needs, and those of
the many visitors who came.
A lack of food provoked murmuring and rebellion among certain of the monks, stirred up by
a monk called Angulas, who took every opportunity to slander the saint under the cloak of his
own great generosity.
The devil, unable to attack Simeon directly, made use of this means to try him.
He, however, lost none of his gentleness towards the rebels.
He reminded them that God never abandoned his servants, and at his prayer, the monastery
stores were filled with grain, which did not run out for three years.
Some Iberians came to join the monks and had their own community on the wonderful mountain,
and it kept strong links with Georgia, where Saint Simeon was greatly venerated.
In 557, following a dreadful vision, Simeon announced that mighty earthquakes would follow,
and he had the monks sing Thropadia, which he composed for sixty days in order to calm
the wrath of God.
As he predicted, the earthquake greatly affected Constantinople and Nicaea, destroying
Nicaea and Regio Calabria, but causing only minor damage in Antioch, thanks to the saint's
protection.
However, a little after this scourge had been averted, an epidemic which had also been predicted
by the saint, hit Antioch.
At the saint's prayers, part of the city was spared, but the calamity reached the wonderful
mountain, where a few of the monks died.
Simeon's much loved disciple, Conon, was one of the victims, and the saint brought him
back to life again.
In spite of the urging of the crowds who wished to receive Holy Communion from this God-bearing
father whose miracles showed forth the authenticity of his faith, Simeon refused to be ordained priest.
Until the day, when at the age of thirty-three, in the year 554, in obedience to a heavenly
voice, he accepted ordination by Bishop Dionysius of Salusia, who climbed the column to
ordain him.
He continued to teach the true faith and to battle against the heresies and superstitions
that had spread, not only among the ordinary people, but also among the eminent men of Antioch.
By his prayers, the man of God also helped the allied armies of the Byzantines, which
were engaged in a campaign against the Seracine Prince Almoudanus, a vassal of corsos, who
was responsible for a bloody persecution of Christians.
He predicted the elevation of just in the second to the throne, and to John the Scholastic,
his consecration as acumenical patriarch.
In Antioch, he announced the death of patriarch Domninos, and predicted that he would be replaced
by Anastasius.
Under his prediction about Justin came true, the latter showed much admiration for the
Holy Stylite, and remained in constant contact with him in order to receive his councils.
Most notably, Justin wrote to the saint to inform him that his daughter was possessed by
a demon.
Simian's response was to assure him that he should thank God, because his daughter would
be healed at the very moment he received his letter.
The emperor, having fallen ill, sought the help of a Jewish charlatan.
Warned of this in a vision, Saint Simian wrote to the patriarch to tell the emperor that
he must renounce such practices which provoke divine anger.
But the sovereign, misled by the imposter, did not obey, and sometime later, in conformity
to what had been revealed to Simian, Justin lost his reason.
On the point of death, he designated Tiberius II as emperor.
After having been, for long years, a living testimony to the Lord's words, he that believe
it on me, the works that I do shall he do, and greater works than these shall he do.
John, chapter 14, verse 12.
Saint Simian, feeling that his earthly sojourn was coming to an end, prophesied in the presence
of two of his disciples, the distribute into which the monastery would be plunged after
his death because of the intrigues of Angulas.
He revealed to them that, from his youth, he had received the grace from God to deprive
himself entirely of food, and that each Sunday, after the liturgy, an angel would bring
him heavenly nourishment.
He then addressed his last spiritual counsels to his disciples and peacefully gave his soul
into God's hands at the age of 71, on the 24th of May in the year 592, thereby joining
the dwelling place of the angels whom he had so well imitated on earth.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.